This is the face at the center of a frantic search...
...ten-month-old Lisa Irwin.
She's got blue eyes, blonde hair, and just two bottom teeth.
She was last seen wearing purple shorts and a purple shirt with kittens on it.
Her mother Debbie told police she put Lisa down to sleep in her crib...
...at around 10:30 Monday night.
When her husband Jeremy came home at 4:00 AM...
...after working an overnight job as an electrician,...
...he found the baby missing and called police.
We've got a five and a half window during which this child could have been taken.
That's a pretty big window.
That's right, yeah.
From an investigative standpoint, that's a big challenge.
It is.
The police immediately issued an Amber Alert...
...and launched a massive search with the FBI,...
...the ATF, the Marshals Service, Mounted Patrols and K-9 units.
The vast majority of child abductions in America are carried out...
...by people who know the child.
Lisa Irwin's parents who have two older children,...
...each from previous marriages are not being called suspects right now...
...but they are being questioned intensively.
And police say they are cooperating.